oh you think you'll be able to get a
pick with Messi now that he's playing in
the MLS you think you might be able to
get close enough where he can sign your
jersey wrong and it's not because Messi
doesn't want to we know he loves his
fans the reason you can't get close is
because of this guy former Navy SEAL
Yasin schweiko is Messi's new bodyguard
and you can't get anything past him it
was hand selected by intermiami's
co-owner David Beckham and he is a
former U.S soldier who served as a Navy
Seal in both Iraq and Afghanistan he's
also an expert in Taekwondo and boxing
and he's fought in multiple MMA fights
in his career but his newest challenge
involves keeping Messi safe and he is
everywhere with him from grocery
shopping to walking down the tunnel his
eyes are constantly scanning to even
when Messi takes Corner kicks he is
always there